where did the FBI go awry
it is a bit of a trick question because
there is an answer and the answer is is
often the case is in the Constitution
there is no place for a federal police
force in the United States Constitution
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it's probably understood that the
direction that it would take if we did
do so it's also why there's no standing
army
let's just look at some recent examples
before we go back and look at the
history of the FBI in ways in which it
has always been problematized by its
politicized character though the nature
of it has expanded and extended and has
gone to a scale and a scope we have
never witnessed before
uh beginning with the election or just
the campaign of President Trump take for
example the January 6 proud boys trial
taking place currently in the District
of Columbia
in that case there has been multiple
documentation of the role of informants
infiltrators and instigators in the
events of January 6th
uh I was there on January 6th I decided
not to take the unauthorized tour of the
Capitol uh I was instead sitting in the
offices of some Trump cabinet officials
as we ultimately watched it unfold I was
there at the behest of President Trump
after representing him in Georgia and
challenging what was taking place in the
election I would note that
president-elect President Trump only
filed one election contest himself that
he was able to legally and that took
place in Georgia
of note the court somehow met even
though the court was required to conduct
a hearing within five days of its filing
on January 6 the Georgia courts had
still just not got around weeks after
its filing to ever hearing the case
indeed they wouldn't decide to hear it
until after January 6 came and went in
fact there was never an evidentiary
hearing on the election contest
president Trump filed in Georgia it was
amidst that frustration and agitation
that people gathered that day on January
6th to hear the president speak and as
the president asked them to do to
peacefully protest outside the capitol
to make sure that our Constitution's
framework for adjudicating election
disputes and controversies which by the
way despite what vice president Mike
Pence would have some people believe
both Vice President John Adams and vice
president Thomas Jefferson had exercised
their constitutional authority to decide
electoral contest going back to the very
founding of our country
and then people got wind is there
outside the capital that that was not
going to occur Pence made the peculiar
decision to wait to release his decision
until right at the beginning of that
presentation which helped put certain
things into motion but things were
already in motion there was an unusual
lack of law enforcement present that day
the capital is the most secure building
in the world particularly on January 6th
uh there are over 2500 people that are
just police officers of the capitol
once again we may be seeing part of our
problem why does the capital even have a
police if they had had regular local
police uh it is the issue of District of
Columbia having its own control and that
being a separate and secondary question
but if it had regular police not under
political control maybe they would have
been properly present that day and there
never would have been any issues because
what happened was there was an unusual
lack of security in some parts of the
capital number one number and number two
there are other members of the police
that were actually guiding protesters
into a compressed area where they would
then be attacked by members of the
Capitol Police that that would lead to
people reacting and responding and only
the people that reacted and responded
were caught on camera or broadcast to
the world or ultimately prosecuted the
Capitol Police who initiated and
instigated that conflict took a complete
walk from any accountability and
responsibility
uh then you had other Capitol Police
that were escorting people into the
building that day while other Capitol
Police were attacking them in other
parts of the building so you know the if
you had just stumbled into it you didn't
know what was happening uh it was still
one of the most unusual Capital riots in
American history and there have been
plenty of capital riots uh through our
history through the history around the
world you can watch the protest
currently taking place in France to see
what real riots look like they usually
involve you know either Farmers dumping
food or manure depending on their choice
that day on the public streets or people
raiding into buildings or or protesting
BLM style has took place in the summer
of 2020 just a few months before those
protests while the people that did those
BLM protests including threatening to
burn down St John's the great historic
church across from the White House not
only did they not get criminally
prosecuted many of them actually got
checks written from the federal
government for the wrongful Smith they
suffered for simply policing that organ
that building that day uh meanwhile
people who took that unauthorized tour
of the capital and had to be some of the
most peaceful rioters in the history of
variety these are people that literally
stayed between the lines half the time
as they're walking through the capitol
these are people who didn't steal any
art the only thing they got taken was a
a now famously memed event someone who
took the little gout the little pedestal
Pelosi's with him there was a gentleman
who put his feet up on Pelosi's desk
what's undisclosed is what came out of
his trial it was the media asking him to
put his feet on Pelosi's desk the uh
these are people who just came in often
directed to do there there were people
around people like Mr Epps apparently
Rupert Murdoch doesn't want people
talking about me Mr Epps because Tucker
crossing the most popular TV News host
in the Modern Age had to resign
yesterday or was separated from his
employment for talking about what
according to the LA Times and the New
York Times for talking about Ray Epps
this was a very unusual case of the man
who got a 60 Minutes profile while
bragging in text to his kid about how he
helped organize January 6 into an event
that could lead to people being
criminally prosecuted and punished while
he himself has never been criminally
prosecuted and punished he's not the
only one they have found in the proud
boys trial a friend of mine colleague
Norm patus is one of the defense lawyers
by the way in Old School Robert
kennedy-style Democratic liberal who's
defending the some of the proud boys
including Joe Biggs in that trial has
found more evidence of government
misconduct and malfeasance and
misfeasance than in any case he's ever
been a part of and he's had the
privilege of being a part of
unfortunately too many in our legal
system going on Decades of
representation you can recognize Norm as
an old civil rights Lefty because he
still has a ponytail like that's still
popular as if it was the 1960s
the in that case what they found is
they're now approaching over a hundred
informants infiltrators and instigators
that day people that were on the
government payroll who were the ones
directing people to go into the building
directing the people to confront the
Capitol Police directing people to try
to take things once they're inside the
building directing people to be
confrontational
uh on the and that is just one aspect of
the degree to which January 6 was very
much a Fed selection not an insurrection
in other aspects you can go into the Q
Anon movement and Oddities about that
movement in terms of who who and what Q
actually was I remember a few months
before the election saying that I had
deep suspicions of the Q Anon movement
because it read and felt like an attempt
to incorporate artificial intelligence
into the ultimate informant infiltrator
instigator kind of event that for years
law enforcement has struggled to
infiltrate various political groups to
try to cause them to do
counterproductive things this is what in
fact cointelpro was all about that will
take us back to the Federal Bureau of
Investigations program to infiltrate
various civil rights organizations
anti-war organizations other
organizations associated with mostly the
political left but not always they also
went at the John Birch Society they also
went at various organizations on the
right that were known for questioning
and being skeptical of institutional
narratives as to matters of war and
other civil rights and civil liberties
issues that the goal was to be able to
infiltrate them without requiring an
individual do so uh that it is it really
a coincidence that what we saw in
Michigan involving these you know the
attempts to rescue Governor whitmer's
political career successfully ultimately
by staging a fake kidnapping that was
basically just some nerds hanging out in
their basements that had no idea about
anything didn't know how to do anything
and it turns out that two-thirds of the
people involved were all federal agents
that they are the ones who originated
the idea they were the ones who came up
with it when they got an honest trial
many of them were acquitted the judge
made sure they didn't get an honest
trial the second time around
the well other well some of the FBI and
agents involved in that case were
ultimately uh found involved in getting
into fights over swinger parties to give
you an idea for their moral values of
that Federal Bureau Investigation office
the person who helped run the fake
kidnapping fake Insurrection Michigan
effort had previously been tried to get
the Michigan militia aligned groups to
Stage such an event at the Michigan
State Capitol during the covet protest
and the lockdown protest where do you
think that person ended up a few weeks
before January 6th ended up in
Washington DC and ended up being one of
the lead FBI agents in charge of the
January 6 cases is that a complete
coincidence that the person who helped
organize and orchestrate the Whitmer
entrapment plot ends up being integral
to the January 6th activities the U.S
prosecutors and the federal and the
media and federal judges sadly have all
been complicit at trying to suppress
this information uh and despite their
efforts the proud boy defense lawyers
have documented more and more and more
of all the people on the federal payroll
and that doesn't even get to Q Anon
which was trying to convince people
leading up to January 6th that the that
there were white hats in the FBI and in
the justice department and in the
intelligence operations in the military
that wanted them to take drastic action
that day that they were actually agents
of the government if they went in and
took dramatic action that day uh was
that not also itself potentially part of
a broader uh attempt by people within
the FBI at the seventh floor level to
get people to take it counterproductive
action
to discredit them and discredit the
election challenge I remember being
there the day before talking to Trump's
lawyers meeting with members of Congress
and I was curious I was like the
National Guard was all over the place by
the way but then would at the request of
the D.C mayor and uh Speaker of the
House Pelosi disappear despite Trump's
request on the day of January 6th so the
National Guard was not present even
though Trump had asked him to be there
had they had the regular Capitol police
presence or the regular guard presence
that have been requested by the
president January 6 never happens
despite all the infiltrators instigators
and informants presence and attempts to
provoke Ray Epps is there the day before
trying to provoke people and people are
spotting him for the provocateur that he
is but I was curious how did Mitch
McConnell how did Nancy Pelosi have such
confidence
that there was going to be no meaningful
vote no meaningful debate on the
Electoral contest challenge given the
Constitutional history that supported it
Senator Cruz senator Paul and others
were getting together an effort to
create an
1886 style commission I'm sorry 1876
style commission to look at what
happened in Georgia what happened in
Arizona what happened in Nevada what
happened in Wisconsin what happened in
Michigan what happened in Pennsylvania
which was as the Wisconsin Supreme Court
would later confirm a lot of illegal
ballots were included in the
presidential count that should not have
been
and the the there were people who voted
who weren't constitutionally qualified
to vote there were people whose votes
were cast in a manner that wasn't
constitutionally qualified and the vote
was counted and canvassed in a way that
wasn't constitutionally qualified
because the Constitution requires that
the rules be established by the
legislature of the state not by secret
court orders not by behind the scenes
executive officials not by Mark Elias
cutting a deal with some corrupt person
not Zuckerberg buying off a local
election office none of that all of
those were legitimate issues and yet
they were incredibly confident that
somehow they were never going to really
see the light of day that they were
going to be demonized in some way uh and
Matt is it really a coincidence that
then January 6 develops the way that it
does now that we know about the
informants and infiltrators and
instigators why did the FBI and the
justice department suddenly lose all
interest in hueq and Hugh and what Q
Anon really was what Q really was there
was an obsession about it leading up to
the election and all of a sudden a
complete lack of Interest as if they
didn't want the world to dig deeper and
to see what might lack but what might be
behind that